- One of the tools you
will very frequently use
in consulting and in many
other professional roles
as well is Excel.
From my experience,
having worked in consulting
at McKinsey for six years,
and having worked with
lots of clients from lots
of corporations, many
people really struggle
to work properly in Excel
and especially to format their
worksheets in a proper way.
So this is what we're
going to discuss today.
I will show you how you
can format your sheets
in a way that they look professional,
I'll show you a couple of tips and tricks
that I picked over time
how you can quickly
in a nice way make sure
that your sheets look
proper and nice and good.
So welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel Firm Learning,
my name is Heinrich
and on my channel, I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So today we're going to tackle this topic
in the following way.
First, I will share a couple
of general remarks and observations,
why it is indeed important
to format your sheets
in a decent way.
And then I will show you
here on my screen, on the PC,
some practical tips
what you can actually do
to format your sheets in a pragmatic way.
So let's start.
Why is it even necessary
to format your sheets?
Well first, it just helps
to bring the key messages across.
An ill-formated sheet will
be much more difficult
for yourself or for your
clients to orientate yourself
in the data.
It is just less accessible,
less intuitive to look at.
But the second reason
is that it just helps
with the look and feel
with the end product quality
of the sheets that you produce.
And indeed in professional services,
every single document every single sheet
that you send out to a client
would just be expected to meet
a higher level of quality.
Then maybe would be okay
internally in the client
organization that you work for.
Many clients walk around
with the expectation that what you deliver
as a BCG consultant, as bank consultant
is just on a higher level
just meets quality
standards, which are higher
than the standards that they
hold themselves accountable
for.
And indeed many consulting
firms have internalized that
so most project leads, most partners,
will hold you accountable.
That you indeed deliver
results to the highest levels.
So that being said, let me share a couple
of practical things
what you can do to just
improve the formatting
improve the look and feel of your sheets.
So let's just
look at this random file.
Lets assume now we want to work with it
format it in a proper way
to make it client ready.
And indeed if you look at this
it looks quite messy for sure
it's not the way how it should be
if you send something like this
to a client.
And let's just look at
the what we see here.
So this apparently is a
merchandise from different seasons.
So for instance, from
an apparel company where
the season code, the supplier
code and then the quantity
and the purchase price
that is available here,
so let's get started.
And the first thing that I
noticed is here that the title
of this fiLe copy of book
one, this is not great, right.
You should never send a
file with such a title.
So let's look into it and
indeed save it in a proper way.
So usually you go with
something like this so the date,
so it started with the year,
then the month, then the day
and maybe then something
like merchandise overview
2021 version one, if we
just start doing this.
So this could be one way.
And then also notice here, this one book,
so this is also always
really something that you
would like to name it a proper way.
So for instance, something
like merchandise.
Overview to make it consistent.
So that's a start, let's
continue by looking into this.
So here you see a mess
of different font sizes,
different font types,
and so on and so forth.
So again, this doesn't
look the way it should.
So lets standardize this
make it the same font size,
make it the same font type.
So at least this is now
all in the same style.
Then one little thing
that I also like to do is
always to insert a little column here
to the left and then the buff.
And then we make this
a little bit smaller,
just quite a little bit of distance.
This just in my experience gives it a nice
and clean look.
Here I don't think we need this underline.
And then here also look at this title
this is like a long, messy title.
So again, one thing
that I often like to do
is to have a main title
and then the subtitle.
So let's potentially
call this something like
merchandise overview as the main title.
And then we can call it
as a subtitle just to say
for this season 2020 and 2021
report
and then we can delete this.
This might potentially be bolded.
Now let's make sure that
here all the columns are of
proper size
just space it out something like this.
Next we want to do the border
so here what I like to do is
always to give the borders here
to the main data, but not
necessarily to the rest.
So we do something like this
and now to make it a bit, look better.
Here you go on view.
And then you take away the grid lines.
My experience really is if
you take away the grid lines
it all looks a bit cleaner.
Now here you go for a dark color
something like this, dark
blue, and then here, the white
and then you could
potentially also bold this.
Now I would also like to here
reduce the distance a little bit.
Now, next thing we can do is
really to freeze the panes
because now currently, if I'm scrolling
I'm not seeing the headers anymore.
So you click here view freeze panes
freeze panes that this, this
thing here above is fixed.
This also makes it look
quite nice, much better.
So let's make sure
that all these number
formats are clean as well.
So you see that this is in some weird way
that this is centered
even though this should
be aligned to the right
so lets just use here the format painter
to make sure that this is
always setup in a proper way.
Now you can see that this is an ID
so I would be fine with that.
I would now, continue to form it.
This though the quantity here
it would always be good to
have some separators, right
for all the thousand.
So let's do that.
Now we can see
that this is done in here for
the purchase price, for sure.
This is something we would
like to do as well, but here,
now let's assume we
know that this is Euro,
then it definitely would be
nice to also include this
in such an accounting format
to have the Euro sign.
So if we now open the old
one and now compare it
to the new one, I hope
that you agree that now
the new one looks nicer and
cleaner to what you had before.
And indeed this really is quick right now
even with explaining it just
took me a couple of minutes.
And usually of course it's even faster
if you just do it on your own.
Just in addition to that
let's imagine you have a
bit of a more complex layout
with maybe different types of
tables next to each other's.
And you'd like to do that as
well, but here are two tips.
So my general recommendation would be
that if you know start
building different tables,
rather build them one under the other,
instead of now adding them here
to the right, this is just
the standard way of modeling.
Especially if you have more complex tables
with maybe times here in the columns
then it's always nicer cleaner to do it
from top to bottom then from left to right
because then you potentially, for instance
could also use the same date fields
then throughout the table
for different lines.
Again, there might be
some exceptions to that
especially if you make
dashboards for instance
then it might make sense to
do it in a different way.
And here indeed, if you would
like to learn more about that
I once made a distinct video
with a couple of tips on how you can
build quite powerful and
easy dashboards in excel.
So I will link it somewhere above here
if you would like to
learn more about that.
But now back to this,
because indeed if here
you would have different types of tables
one after the other.
So how would you do that right?
And let's imagine we might have even more
so here I'll probably do it.
Yes, I would do it exactly like this right
so I just here then copy the title.
Of course, this might also
be now a different title.
And then I would leave
like one line distance and
then probably also make this
distance a little bit shorter.
And by that now you could
build all kinds of stuff
one after or one below the other,
and then keep such a nice clean look
for all of this to keep going.
Now let me end
with an additional little
formatting convention.
And this is especially
important if you're now working
with more complex files,
more complex models.
Because indeed, usually it's
important also with colors
distinguish the input sets
from the output or the calculated sets.
So let's imagine now we would
like to calculate the price
per unit, just here to
make a basic example.
So now probably what we
would like to do is just
form it this over here, just
to have it in the same way.
Now we would calculate that by
dividing the total purchase
price by the units.
So just like this.
Okay. And now what we would love to do is
as you can can see that this
is now a calculated field
and now not really an input field
rather we just input the raw data.
And here one convention is
to color calculated fields
in a dark blue, something
like this, for instance.
So here now on first side
you see that the black sets are sets
that you hard copy that you hard input
and then the blue sets
are calculated ones.
So again, this just really
helps if you have a more complex
larger model to really understand
what are all the inputs,
what are the sets that you
hard coded, hard typed into it,
what are all the output
sets, which probably
you should not directly
manipulate, but rather
they are values derived from
the value of some other sets.
And again, if you'd like to learn more
I have more videos like this
on Excel for people working
in professional services.
I will link a playlist
somewhere above here,
where you find all the
videos that I currently have
on my channel.
And if you would like to
see more content like this
subscribe because on my channel
I will create more videos on
Excel in the future as well.
So now I would love to hear from you
do you have any little tips and tricks
that you'd like to share
to other people here in the
Firm Learning community?
Let me know your tips
in the comment section.
And as you know, I will do my very best to
answer every single
comment that you write.
If you took away any value
at all out of this video
please smash the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe
to my channel to stay up
to date on all my content.
If you want to see even more from me
follow me on my Instagram.
And recently also started
to become more active
on Twitch and on TikTok.
So you find links to both
of these platforms below
in the video description.
So check these out.
Now I also want to give a shout out
to all the members of Firm Learning.
Thank you so much
for supporting me for your
contribution for this channel.
This is really making a difference.
And if you want to
become a members as well
and benefit from some member-only perks
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
to learn more about this.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
I'm releasing weekly videos
every single Saturday here on my channel.
So looking forward to see
you again next Saturday
until then good weekend to all of you.
This is Heinrich bye-bye.